hallo liebe leute wir haben heute besuch
von dana von rund adventure hallo
danach kommt aus den usa wie ihr
vielleicht wisst und lebt seit vielen
jahren in deutschland
und trotzdem gibt es manchmal noch ein
paar kleine schwierigkeiten beim deutsch
sprechen auch wenn du schon sehr gut
deutsch spricht dankeschön und danach
hatte heute eine idee zu einem thema was
wir schon lange machen wollten
und zwar geht es darum wie man auf
deutsch etwas höflich ausdrückt und
damit verbunden ist wie kann man den
konjunktiv zwei im deutschen richtig
benutzen ja kreativ klingt erst mal
beängstigend
ja aber ich weiss ich mache viele damit
also auch deswegen so eingesetzt
aber es ist eigentlich gar nicht so
schwierig und heute zeigen wir euch drei
typische fehler und wie ihr die
vermeiden könnte
[Musik]
der erste fehler mit dem konjunktiv ist
den konjunktiv gar nicht zu benutzen
dana hat hier ein paar beispiele setzte
die duale selber nicht gesagt hast aber
das sind sätze die ich schon gehört habe
und zwar von euch in den kommentaren
oder manchmal auch von menschen mit
denen ich zusammen unterwegs bin ich
will einen kaffee
ich will einen kaffee klingt eigentlich
einfach aber auf deutsch ist das
wirklich etwas unhöflich und das
interessante ist wenn man auf deutsch
etwas bestellt und einen wunsch aus
drückt man benutzt man eigentlich immer
den konjunktiv denn der konjunktiv ist
höflicher und der richtige satz oder den
ich euch empfehlen würde ist ich hätte
gerne einen kaffee korrigieren sie bitte
meinen text das dann bitte richtig hätte
das ist freilich das stimmt aber wenn
man das geschrieben sieht das ist etwas
was oft leute schreiben zum beispiel
unter unseren videos und sie schreiben
etwas auf deutsch und sie möchten gerne
dass wir den text korrigieren und dann
schreibt jemand korrigieren sie bitte
manchmal schreckt man korrigieren sie
bitte den text das klingt für mich
nicht lese wenn man es so freundlich
sagt wie du manchmal ist es auch eine
internationale wenn ich etwas sage wie
korrigieren sie bitte meinen text ich
kann das sehr höflich sagen und dann ist
es okay aber im schriftlichen mir kommt
es ja darauf an wie ich das lese und ich
kann das lesen als positiv oder negativ
und ich denke es ist immer höflicher den
konjunktiv zu benutzen und hier könnt
ihr zum beispiel sagen könntest du bitte
meinen text korrigieren das klingt immer
super höflich der zweite fehler ist wenn
ihr etwas wörtlich übersetzt also ihr
habt etwas im englischen und dann
übersetzt sie es ins deutsche oder ihr
habt vielleicht etwas gelernt schon im
deutschen und übersetzt das jetzt in der
nächsten situation genauso zum beispiel
ich wünsche ich hätte gewusst dass das
kommt von englisch gemacht und im
englischen sagst du oasch das ist ja
präsens im deutschen benutzt man das
allerdings nicht denn im deutschen
benutzt man in diesem fall den
konjunktiv und wann benutzt man
überhaupt den konjunktiv man benutzt den
immer dann wenn etwas nicht real ist
oder nicht real existiert zum beispiel
wenn man einen wunsch ausdrückt dann ist
das etwas was man noch nicht ab sondern
gerne hätte also dass es etwas was
nämlich existiert oder wenn man einen
vorschlag macht oder wenn man eine
bedingung ausdrückt ich wünschte ich
hätte das früher gelernt richtig ja oder
ich wünschte der konjunktiv würde gar
nicht existieren ja das haus aber man
kann auch manchmal wünschen ohne den
konjunktiv benutzt zb ich wünsche dir
einen schönen tag noch in dem fall den
du benutzt hast sagte mann
ich wünschte weil das ist ja nicht
wirklich passiert du hast von einer sehr
realen situation gesprochen aber wenn
ich sage ich wünsche dir einen schönen
tag dann tue ich das wirklich jetzt
gerade in diesem moment wünsche ich dir
schönen tag diese fehler habe ich auch
vor ein paar tagen gemacht
ich habe angerufen und gesagt ich hätte
gerne eine reservierung machen bitte ja
so ist mein handy
ja ja und ich sag ja genau
nein er hat er hat verstanden was ich
meinte das war in ordnung habe ja ich
hätte gerne eine reservierung machen
bitte und woher wusstest du dass es
falsch ist würde ich einfach nach stefan
stefan stefan mein mann davon war so
freundlich mir zu sagen was ist frei
ja genau nein ich würde gerne und ich
sage diese fehler ich hätte gerne weil
man sagt ich hätte gerne einen kaffee
und auf englisch ich hätte gerne einen
kaffee ist ein like a coffee ja ich
hätte gerne einen kaffee
ich hätte gerne eine reservierung machen
der wood like to make a wave ist total
logisch wenn du es jetzt erklärt aber es
ist tatsächlich so dass es im deutschen
vom verb abhängt wie man den konjunktiv
bildet und man benutzt nur hätte in
diesem café fall weil man den kaffee
haben möchte also man sagt ich hätte
gerne einen kaffee weil ich habe ihn
nicht wirklich und man benutzt dann den
diesen surrealen fall diesen konjunktiv
um diesen wunsch auszudrücken ich hätte
gerne einen kaffee aber mit anderen
werben muss man etwas anderes benutzen
zum beispiel ich wünschte dass ich
sollte das ich könnte das und in diesem
fall würdest du würden benutzen ich
würde gerne eine reservierung machen
auch diese fehle
eine miss germany video gemacht ich habe
auf der straße gefragt oder gesagt ich
hätte gerne des ndr bla bla bla bla
statt zu sagen ich würde gerne wissen
und das ist für mich ganz schwierig
werden
es ist schon in meinem kopf ja und in
diesem fall kann es zu sagen ich würde
gerne wissen oder ich wüsste gerne und
das bringt uns zu punkt 3
wie bildet man den konjunktiv oder es
kann sein dass wir den konjunktiv falsch
bildet wusstest du dass dass es
verschiedene varianten gibt es den
konjunktiv zu bilden und das schwierige
ist im deutschen gibt es zwar also es
gibt eine richtige möglichkeit den
konjunktiv zu bilden und das ist das was
ich schon beschrieben habe du nimmst es
die im perfekt fahren also das simple
passt sagt man dazu im englisch- und
fuchs noch einen umlaut hinzu zum
beispiel es ist den umlaut nicht immer
hinzu aber in den meisten fällen zum
beispiel haben hatte hätte und andere
varianten sind können konnte könnte
es gibt aber einige wörter die benutzten
diese form nicht du kannst dieses diese
form mit jedem werk bilden und das ist
das interessante zum beispiel wissen ist
diese form wüsste ich wüsste gerne was
sie darüber denken
es gibt aber auch eine zweite variante
und dies mit würden
ich würde gerne wissen und dann benutzt
würde plus den infiniti iv ich würde
gerne wissen was du denkst
ich glaube ja dass sie das mündet nein
das benutze ich also ich hab ich glaub
ich hab nie
ich wüsste gesagt das ist ein bisschen
schwierig ist ist zu wissen wann benutzt
man die original konjunktiv formen und
wann benutzt man die würden form und
generell kann man sagen dass die
original konjunktiv form bei einigen
werben ganz normal ist und bei anderen
werben klingt das super formell oder
besonders touristik bietet oder sehr
künstlich ausgedrückt bei wüsste ist das
zum beispiel schon ein bisschen an der
grenze und ich zeige oder ich lese jetzt
einfach mal die vor die normal sind mit
der original konjunktiv von zum beispiel
sein
ich wäre man benutzt immer ich wäre man
sagt nicht ich würde sein haben hätte
können könnte müssen müsste dürften
dürfte wollen wollte also man sagt nicht
ich würde wollen sondern ich wollte
gerne woanders sein sollen sollte
brauchen bräuchte wissen wüsste und
kommen käme also das sind eigentlich nur
zehn werben und mit allen anderen werben
benutzt man eigentlich immer die würde
form und das ist etwas was man einfach
leider einmal lernen muss und was leider
etwas nervig ist bist du hier live
sie sagen oft ja deutsche sprache
schwere sprache habe ich so sagen die
deutschen selber ihr die deutsche
sprache schwere sprache aber ich mag zu
sagen
deutsche sprache schwere sprache aber
auch sehr schöne sprache es ist auch
sehr schön er sich aber auch schon
es gibt ein paar interessante sachen du
hast ja auch ein buch darüber
geschrieben das verlinken wir noch mal
hier unten da könnt ihr ein bisschen
sehen über darüber wie dana deutsch
gelernt hat und komische sachen
rausgefunden hat über die leute sprache
und wir haben heute auch ein tolles
video gedreht hier über ein sehr sehr
wichtiges und interessantes und auch
sensibles thema und ihr könnt das auf
danach channel sehen aber jetzt noch
nicht erst in ungefähr drei bis vier
wochen
ihr solltet aber unbedingt schon mal da
nachts channel abonnieren denn dort gibt
es auch viele andere interessante themen
für menschen die deutsch lernen und den
channel findet ihr jetzt ja wanted
adventure abonniert den kanal und danke
dass du da warst ja das war super
wünschte ich hätte das früher gelernt
aber jetzt habe ich es gelernt und jetzt
werde ich den fehler nie wieder machen
nie wieder etwas testen wir jetzt gleich
im restaurant wenn wir versorgen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]